here are the guidelines if you're having
thanksgiving in california thankfully i
will be out of this state for
thanksgiving i would have ignored the
rules even if i were here
all gatherings must include no more than
three households
including hosts and guests so you know
you've got uh
three aunts and their families who could
come over no
i'm sorry you got to pick two old aunt
beth
doesn't get to come to thanksgiving this
year she's the least favorite aunt you
can only pick two that they can come
over but
the other one no because if you invite
two people over
you won't get coronavirus but if you
invite a third person over you will get
coronavirus
i guess that's just science they
they cannot last for more than two hours
again if you have a two hour
thanksgiving
dinner you're okay but at two and a half
hour thanksgiving dinner you will get
coronavirus that is i guess
science uh gatherings that occur
outdoors are safer than indoor
gatherings so all gatherings must be
outside i guess like the first
thanksgiving
that's really going back in history
you're not allowed to go indoors because
if you go indoors
you will get coronavirus by the way i i
have been ignoring all
all of these stupid rules from the very
beginning the masks and the social
distancing
and the indoors and the outdoors and
i've been ignoring all of it and guess
what
i'm having a great time my life is
totally fine
my friends lives are totally fine my
family's lives totally fine
you can do it you can do it it's okay
you don't need to listen
to these idiotic politicians those who
are at the thanksgiving gathering
quote may remove their face coverings
briefly to eat or drink as long as they
stay six feet away from everyone outside
their own household
and then they have to put the face
covering back on the minute they're done
with the activity
you get one little spoonful of cranberry
sauce in there but you better put that
mask on i don't care if it smears the
sauce you got to do it
otherwise otherwise you will get
coronavirus
face coverings can be removed to meet
urgent medical needs
such as taking an asthma inhaler if you
get an attack so you are allowed
you're allowed to take the mask off if
you are dying
you can take it off to get life-saving
medicine but otherwise you better put it
on
no singing no chanting no shouting no
physical exertion of any kind
is permitted if you do have to sing at
the table you've got to do it very
quietly in a speaking voice
behind a mask and
then you have to go home within two
hours
obviously none of that is based on
science science itself has
very little to say about any of those
questions because those are ethical
and philosophical and political
questions and
all of them are not only medically
pointless
but but politically horrifically
perverse and corrosive
so you should ignore all of that i
intend on going to a thanksgiving
dinner and hugging and kissing everybody
and sharing plates and maybe even
sharing drinks with people
and singing very loudly and never ever
ever even considering wearing my mask
and i encourage all of you to do the
same because this is all very stupid
and these politicians are not going to
let off even one little bit
on this grip of power that they've
stolen from us pointlessly
unconstitutionally unless we take it
from them so just take it just ignore
them
no reason to pay any attention to them i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you